[Music]
so what is gravity I'll bet most of you
think it's what go hose up must come
down is that right well sorta but not
really technically the law of gravity is
an equation it is F equals G times m1
times m2 divided by R squared where G is
the universal gravitational constant m1
and m2 are the masses of the two objects
and R is the distance between them
squared that was easy right probably not
what does this actually mean well it
means that well everything is attracted
to everything else and what I mean by
that is that if you have two objects any
two objects they are attracted to each
other okay let's try and wrap our minds
around this what happens when you drop a
rock off a cliff it falls to the earth
right well yes but something else
happens you see the law of gravity says
that both objects the rock and the earth
are attracted to each other this means
that the rock Falls towards the earth
and the earth Falls towards the rock but
wait a second you mean to tell me that
if the earth Falls up to meet the rock
yes that's exactly what I'm saying and
the reason you don't see the earth fall
up to meet the rock is because the
objects move towards each other
proportionate to their respective masses
the earth is much much much more massive
than the rock so it moves a very very
small distance and the rock is much less
massive so it moves farther with respect
to the earth maybe a better way to
understand gravity is to take two
teenagers in spacesuits and place them
far out in space away from all the
planets and the stars
turns out they will be attracted to each
other I'm not talking about that kind of
attraction see they have mass and since
they have mass they will move towards
each other they are attracted to each
other maybe one more thing might help
have you played with two magnets near
the magnets with the North and the South
Poles when you take the magnets and put
them closer to each other they move
together they are attracted to each
other and the closer they are the
stronger the attraction think of the
mass of the object like the strength of
a magnet
and the distance between the objects
like the distance between the two
magnets now understand I'm not saying
that gravity and magnetism are the same
they just behave in a similar way let's
think of one other thing astronauts you
know astronauts they weigh less on the
moon than on the earth
why is that well you see the moon is
less massive than the earth therefore it
has a smaller gravitational pull on the
astronaut what's like the moon is a
weaker magnet they aren't as attracted
to each other distance also plays a role
think back to playing with a magnet the
pull of the magnets towards each other
are stronger when they are closer
together the same is true of gravity for
example the Sun is the most massive
object near the earth it dictates most
of the gravitational forces in our solar
system it is very very massive but it is
relatively far away so even though the
Sun is a much stronger magnet so to
speak it is a long ways away
therefore the attraction isn't as strong
so let's look back at that law of
gravity the equation F equals G times m1
m2 divided by R squared you see the
force of gravity is equal to a number
that's that Universal gravitational
constant G times the mass of object 1
times the mass of object to think of m1
being the mass of the Sun and m2 being
the mass full of the earth and then we
divide by the distance between them
squared this determines the force of
attraction between the Sun and the earth
you could just as easily plug in your
mass and the Earth's mass and the
distance between you and the center of
the earth and find out how much you are
attracted to the earth and the earth
attracted to you so what's gravity
everything is attracted to everything
else everything oh one last thing just
to make you wonder what causes gravity
why are two objects with mass attracted
to each other well the answer is we
don't know the cause of gravity remains
a mystery to scientists
we don't really know conclusively what
causes gravity
it is one of the great mysteries of
science
you